Red Bull it made this guy a 15 billion
Fortune but the recipe for his success
wasn't just sugar carbonated water
caffeine and taurine whatever that is
there was another major Innovation
Dietrich matoshits was Austria's richest
man when he died in October and he and
his team managed to turn red bull into
so much more than just an energy drink
uh one of the very clever things they've
done is turn RedBoard into a story brand
they tell stories and so one of the
things they did was a light on events
and in particular extreme sports things
like cliff diving or mountain biking
these weren't terribly expensive to back
because they were comparatively little
known and yet Red Bull has made them big
and produced a lot of content that they
can then further promote the brand with
whether snowboarders space jumps or more
recently owning soccer and Formula One
racing teams Red Bull has spread its
marketing tentacles more deeply into
sport than any brand before and
matoshits got lucky because the approach
coincided with the rise of social media
and digital video rather than paying for
newspaper or TV ads videos of extreme
sports could go viral at little to no
extra cost and his brand was splashed
all over it that's what really gave Red
Bull Wings